[Music]
look
sometimes in esports there's no room for
error whether you're stuck
in a clutch situation over time or
you're one hit away from losing at all
the point is you're not taking any
chances but sometimes
when the mood strikes and you're feeling
confident it's more fun to
disrespect your opponent these are the
plays that give a whole new meaning to
the term
psychological warfare and just before we
get into that make sure you are
subscribed
to the channel so you never miss a video
just like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 disrespectful
plays
kicking us off at number 10 is brokey
with a cheeky team kill at
dreamhack open fall 2020. look
it's it's effective okay that's what it
is it is effective
it's it's still around at the very least
for fades but he
executes cold down nine to four against
north brokey knew his team couldn't
afford to lose another round
so with an open hand he began
dismantling
everything in sight but when he saw a
clean shot onto cajun b
he realized that he could take the round
and bm a little by sacrificing
coldzera for a brutal kill cole will
find another
occasion in a one-on-two if there's a
man you want to have it is him
can he get it done yes he can but
unfortunately for him
that kill wasn't cajun now disrespecting
the enemy
is one thing but your own team's economy
that's downright savage
you know the phrase kick them when
they're down well showmaker certainly
does
and he took it to a whole new level
against g2
which is why he takes the number nine
spot on our list
oh no that is bm and let me remind you
folks
for show maker and for damn one gaming
this is personable this score is a
translated quote but he wants to crush
you two
into pieces as soon as possible now
damon are no strangers to displaying
some bad manners
the team is notorious for making wild
and sometimes unnecessary place
to shatter their opponent's morale but
things got
personal against g2 during the 2020
world semi-finals
showmaker wanted to remind the eu squad
of their disappointing history at worlds
so he spammed the emotes of the teams
that previously dunked on europe
has anyone really made them sweat when
you do have some of the tape the world
championship of don juan
dropping a game it was from jdg who did
skirmish them but
oh my show maker
solve the words oh no that is bm
jesus show maker the man has a family
taking the number eight spot on our list
is a play that will make you drop some
f's in the comments
minecraft steve is a pretty new addition
to smash ultimate and few players have
really taken him to the heights of
competition but his unique play style
has offered some creative new tools for
disrespect
take this play from rockman who stopped
before killing m marco at mega smash
mondays
to build an f in the middle of the stage
that's right the man built a memorial to
his opponent's failure before he'd even
died
wait wait a minute hold on yo welcome to
ultimate baby
coming in at number seven now is a play
from og
that's nothing short of soul breaking
after shocking the world
winning ti 8 and cementing themselves in
esports history
o.g came back the next year dripping
with confidence and an
absolutely dizzying number of ways to
disrespect their opponents
my god just relentless i was skeptical
in the start especially about this
bottom lane but
things are looking great right now
mainly because our teeth are okay
they're
actually just put the flag down build a
wall and that's easy can't cross it
but nothing was more disrespectful than
their late-game dive onto
newbie where thompson took the full heat
of the fountain as the rest of his team
aided in the psychological warfare
nothing is really going here in thompson
he's the man that's going going going
into the fountain once again
bathed in the glory of the radiant
thompson
he just does not give a crap anna will
give all the life
this is just fountain farming
gee you got it this is salt breaking
[Applause]
number six on our list is a disciplinary
play from electronic that could have
gone
horribly wrong i have never seen
anything like that unbelievable and he
still gets the double kill thank god
during the group stage of the esl pro
league season seven finals
electronic found himself in a sneaky
situation against
faze as he tiptoed his way onto b site
with kerrigan
unaware of him lurking behind
electronics showed incredible trigger
discipline
but what happened next was pure bm
he's gonna have the great trigger
discipline spotted exists there already
on the cross and he knows where kerrigan
is of course
just waiting oh goodness me this thing
cannot be possible
he's managed at least to get rid of
kerrigan at all that could have gone way
way worse for electronic he almost
caked it yeah that somehow
worked what's even crazier is navi ended
up winning the round
kerrigan had to have been shaking his
head after that one
at our halfway point now is logix who
showed us why spawn camping in overwatch
can backfire on you
real fast after a rough defense against
the justice on havana the defiant was
struggling to make cart progress with
stratus and ark's pharmacy reigning
well justice from above them but no one
had it worse than logix who was pinced
into his own spawn and subsequently bm
by stratus
but little did he know this was logic's
plan
all along al and the one time gods isn't
on diva
could cost them big when that's ready
objects around the back trying to
survive
give it to the hell oh no he pulled out
the mccree
flashbangs him and shuts him down by
switching to mccree logics was able to
land a clean flashbang on pharah and
hilariously taught mercy before
finishing the job karma's a [ __ ] in it
we give it to logics look at this guys
you're trying to install
nobody's faster than logics this was so
good
i absolutely love this it's just the uh
the disrespect
switches heroes instant flashbang
headshots
and not once but he gets the pharah and
then the mercy
taking the number four spot on our list
is the most stylish player in marvel vs
capcom 3
marlin pie in fighting games you can
always kill your opponent with a boring
bread and butter combo
but why do that when you can style on
them with an unnecessary extension
instead marvel players have always been
known for flashy combos but
none were more notorious than marlin
pike who showed the world his incredible
talent with dr doom at
ceo 2012.
wow great confirm standing medium call
zoom plasma beam
cancelled into paper and side exchange
wow in the middle of the screen like
that huh oh
what what what what oh my god
and this wasn't the only time either
marlin pie made a name for himself
disrespecting and demoralizing players
who
dared to challenge him
oh you gotta bring him you're gonna
bring it out the doom this is gonna be
hard for him to block
yeah it was harder on the block it is it
really is i mean it doesn't make your
block any
coming in at number three is the first
international knife kill invalorent
courtesy of sentinel's bmr
extraordinaire
dapper we not only see the first
international knife
but the second international tea bag now
when it comes to trolling
dapper is undoubtedly na's go-to
expert he's proven time and time again
that he's willing to risk his life in
the name of good old-fashioned
disrespect
and sure sonic's players were playing in
n a but they're australian and dapper
taking the knife to dizzy to finish
things off
technically makes this the first ever
international knife in ballarant history
okay now it's just dizzy in a 1v5
catches oh
at the runner-up spot is a straight-up
ridiculous round in street fighter 4
from the beast himself
daigo umahara what a first round from
tiger
i said he might try something as soon as
he's in his bracket but i didn't see
that coming saying
so spamming and fighting games can be
really frustrating
but at the highest level it's just
embarrassing
if your opponent has the audacity to use
the same move
over and over again it means they have
no respect for you
or your ability to read them and that's
exactly what happened to gamerbee when
digo started off the grand finals at
dreamhack winter 2013.
the first shoryuken was a reasonable
anti-air and
so was the second but the third that was
just
cruel and the fourth my god but
really try a few gutsy things with that
lead he's got i've been in winner's
bracket
and we're off great reaction there you
go
oh oh walk into the neutral oh
and finally taking the number one spot
on our list
is a sneaky beaky nice spot from simple
during the iem global challenge group
stage in 2020
navi were in a close matchup against
furia with a score of eight to seven
which made it all the more surprising
when simple made the cheeky decision to
hide in nuke fence with his knife out
and the nato opened squeaky oh look it's
so cheeky okay it's a very viable
strategy by the way if anyone thinks
he's suddenly trolling in an a7 game
that is a
very easy one shot knife and he's
definitely oh that's
unreal unbelievable scenes he took off
for silencer as well for showboats
in a display of pure disrespect simple
tour through furious players
as they desperately use a ladder without
knowing what
lurked below that is a very easy one
shot knife and he's demonstrating
oh that's unreal unbelievable
scenes he took off the silencer as well
for showboats
well there you go guys those were our
most disrespectful plays in esports
we think they don't get more
disrespectful than that but are there
any good ones out there
that we missed out let us know in the
comments thanks for watching and i'll
see you all in the next one
it's the best one i've seen from them so
far even though they lost the filthy
there they could get the read but razer
why are you trying to take a [ __ ]
how does that work sipping how do you
lose that sipping that is the worst
weapon to take a fight with in that
situation and razer wins it regardless
dexter will take the match old man
jarvis coming in clutch
oh boy if you need to let out more rage
and frustration michael i understand